what we're going to do in this video is
show that if we have two different
triangles that have
one pair of sides that have the same
length so these blue sides in each of
these triangles have the same length and
they have two pairs of angles where for
each pair the corresponding angles have
the same measure so this gray angle here
has the same measure as this angle here
and then these double orange arcs show
that this angle acb has the same measure
as angle d f e
and so we're going to show that if you
have two of your angles and a side that
have the same measure or length that we
can always create a series of rigid
transformations that maps one triangle
onto the other or another way to say it
they must be congruent by the rigid
transformation definition of congruency
and the reason why i wrote angle side
angle here and angle angle side is to
realize that these are equivalent
because if you have two angles
then you know what the third angle is
going to be
so for example in this case right over
here if we know that we have two pairs
of angles that have the same measure
then that means that the third pair must
have the same measure as well
so we'll know this as well so if you
really think about it if you have the
side between the two angles that's
equivalent to having an angle an angle
and a side because as long as you have
two angles the third angle is also going
to have the same measure as the
corresponding third angle on the other
triangle
so let's just show a series of rigid
transformations that can get us from a b
c to d e f
so the first step you might imagine
we've already shown that if you have two
segments of equal length that they are
congruent you can have a series of rigid
transformations that maps one onto the
other so what i want to do is
map segment
a
c
onto
df and the way that i could do that
is i could translate point a to be on
top of point d
so then i'll call this a prime and then
when i do that this segment ac is going
to look something like this i'm just
sketching it right now it's going to be
in that direction but then and the whole
the rest of the triangle is going to
come with it so let's see the rest of
that orange side side a b
is going to look something
like that but then we can do another
rigid transformation which is rotate
about point d or point a prime they're
the same point now
so that point c coincides with point f
and so just like that you would have two
rigid transformations that get us that
map ac onto
df and so a prime
where a is mapped is now equal to d and
f is now equal to c prime
but the question is where does point b
now sit
and the realization here is that angle
measures are preserved and since angle
measures are preserved we are either
going to have a situation
where this angle let's see this angle is
angle
c a b gets preserved so then it would be
c prime a prime
and then b prime would have to sit
someplace on this ray for if we're going
to preserve the measure of angle c a b
b prime is going to sit someplace along
that ray
because an angle is defined by two rays
that intersect at the vertex or start at
the vertex and because this angle is
preserved that's the angle that is
formed by these two rays you could say
ray ca and ray cb
we know that b prime also has to sit
someplace on this ray as well
so b prime also has to sit someplace
on this ray and i think you see where
this is going
if b prime because these two angles are
preserved because this angle and this
angle are preserved have to sit
someplace on both of these rays they
intersect at one point this point right
over here that coincides with point e so
this is where b prime would be so that's
one scenario in which case we've sewn
that you can get a series of rigid
transformations from this triangle to
this triangle but there's another one
there is a circumstance where the angles
get preserved but instead of being on
instead of the angles being on the i
guess you could say the bottom right
side of this blue line you could imagine
the angles get preserved such that they
are on the other side so the angles
get preserved so that they are on the
other side of that blue line and then
the question is in that situation where
would b prime end up
well actually let me draw this a little
bit let me do this a little bit more
exact let me replicate these angles
so i'm going to draw an arc like this
an arc like this
and then i'll measure this distance
it's like it's
just like this we've done this in other
videos when we're trying to replicate
angles
so it's like that far and so let me draw
that on this point right over here this
far
so if the angles are on that side of
line i guess we could say df or a prime
c prime
we know that b prime would have to sit
someplace on this ray
so let me draw that as neatly as i can
someplace on this
ray
and it would have to sit someplace on
the ray formed by the other angle so let
me see if i can draw that as neatly as
possible
so let me
make a
make a arc like this
i probably did that a little bit bigger
than i need to
but hopefully we it serves our purposes
i measure this distance right over here
if i measure that distance over here
it would get us right
over there
so b prime either sits on this ray
or
it could sit
or and it has to sit i should really say
on this ray
that goes through this point and this
point
and it has to sit on this ray and you
can see where these two rays intersect
is right over there so the other
scenario is if the angles get preserved
in a way that they're on the other side
of that blue line well then b prime is
there
and then we could just add one more
rigid transformation to our series of
rigid transformations which is
essentially or is a reflection across
line df or a prime c prime why will that
work to map b prime onto e well because
reflection is also a rigid
transformation so angles are preserved
and so as this angle gets flipped over
it's preserved as this angle gets
flipped over the measure of it i should
say is preserved and so that means we'll
go to that first case where then these
rays would be flipped onto these rays
and b prime would have to sit on that
intersection and there you have it if
you have two angles and if you have two
angles you're going to know the third if
you have two angles and a side that have
the same measure or length if we're
talking about an angle or a side well
that means that they are going to be
congruent triangles